all right as you're watching our
monologue think about these three simple
questions do we as a constitutional
republic do we have the right to
sovereignty do you believe in borders do
you believe we have a right to protect
those borders to protect our sovereignty
now for weeks we've been warning you
about the looming crisis at our southern
border now at least 5,000 migrants have
already arrived in the Mexican border
city of Tijuana with thousands more
still on the way now they're all
demanding entry into the u.s. most under
an asylum designation but over the
weekend we saw several hundreds of the
so-called asylum seekers look at what
they're doing
they're rushing the US border they're
hurling rocks bottles other objects over
the fencing three Border Patrol officers
were struck we have broken windows
damaged vehicles of Border Patrol in
order to protect the border in
themselves u.s. Border Patrol agents
fired non-lethal tear gas to disperse
the mob of migrants trying to break
across by force
earlier today border patrol chief Karl
apropos she described this tense in this
scary situation
take a look our agents were being
assaulted a large group rushed the area
and they were throwing rocks and bottles
at my men and women putting them in
harm's way as well as other members of
the caravan we needed to disperse the
group and with that assaultive nature it
was it was imperative that we disperse
them from the area so it wasn't because
they seem to be running toward the
United States it was because they were
hinting you're your Patrol Border Patrol
with rocks and bottles yes sir they were
I mean while over Pig News CNN San
Diego's chief Border Patrol agent Rodney
Scott had this to say about those who
rushed the border take a look
explain the decision to use the tear gas
because that is one question I think
people have this morning so are one of
our primary missions is to make sure
that we keep the border safe and secure
a kind of challenge that this was a
peaceful protest or the majority of
these people were claiming asylum we
needed up making about 42 arrests only
eight of those or females and there were
only a
you children involved the vast majority
of the people were dealing with their
adult males similar to what we saw the
first wave of the caravan that came up
about a week or so ago the group
immediately started throwing rocks and
debris at our at our agents taunting the
agents of once our agents were assaulted
and the numbers started growing we had
you know two or three agents at a time
initially facing hundreds of people at a
time they deployed to your gas to
protect themselves and to protect the
border if they were truly asylum seekers
they would have just walked up with
their hands up and surrendered and that
did not take place and just a few
moments ago on the story chief Scott
also had this to say about the migrants
let's take a look we took this caravan
very serious from day one it's like no
caravan we've ever seen before you've
heard it reports that caravans happen
all the time that's true but not
caravans that have a propensity for this
type of violence and not these massive
numbers of people we watched as they
came up through Mexico the violence that
they were subjecting the Mexican police
and military to we prepared accordingly
more violent than previous caravans this
is a serious situation we don't want
anybody to get hurt and we do know a lot
about those now trying to cross our
border by the way even on conspiracy TV
MSNBC and reporter actually stumbled
upon the truth and told it the majority
of migrants at the border they are not
asylum seekers they're mostly men
looking for a better life and I believe
that probably about 99% of them but
we'll tell you more in a second take a
look she says that she is hoping that
they give her a chance to work that's
what we've heard from this family this
family hasn't really talked about asylum
per se they are saying that they don't
even want to come to the United States
and definitely they're going to be
asking for permission to work for three
to four years from what we've seen the
majority are actually men and some of
these men have not articulated that need
for asylum instead they have talked
about you know going to the United
States for a better life and to find
work Border Security should not be a
partisan issue
while most individuals who try to
immigrate into the u.s. I understand it
they come from countries no
opportunities poverty good decent people
they want what we often take for granted
it's not always the case bad people
constantly trying to gain access into
our country I've been down to the water
more than anyone else that I know in the
media about 13 times I've witnessed
illicit drug smuggling operations drug
warehouses human trafficking violent
gang members arrested
I've sat through a briefing with then
Governor Rick Perry showed what 642
thousand crimes committed against Texans
alone at the hands of illegal immigrants
in just a seven-year period this week a
suspected illegal immigrant charged with
killing a Texas teacher during a hit and
run incident and according to the DHS
they've identified along with Mexican
officials over 500 criminals that have
infiltrated the migrant caravan bad
people moving among those that want
opportunity those with criminal records
always actively trying to get into the
u.s. in order to protect the safety and
security of everyone living here we've
got to protect our borders if we had a
secure wall right now nobody would be in
harm's way in lieu of a robust border
wall this country will always be
vulnerable you saw it this weekend look
at the videos look at the pictures as
agents forced to defend themselves
against hundreds of so-called asylum
seekers who attempting to break into the
United States by force by the way those
who seek asylum don't generally assault
u.s. Border Patrol officers and they're
about ten thousand or up to ten thousand
more people coming but not according to
the left liberals Democrats the media
now waging a full-scale smear campaign
against those defending our rule of law
our country one Democratic senator
actually tweeted then deleted a
suggestion that the Border Patrol
engaged in chemical weapons attack why
by firing tear gas Rihanna
called the Border Patrol's actions quote
terrorism and then there's the
democratic well I guess Rockstar Acacio
Cortes tweeting quote this asking to be
considered a refugee and applying for
status isn't a crime it wasn't for
Jewish families fleeing Germany it
wasn't for targeted families fleeing
Rwanda it wasn't for Communities fleeing
war-torn
Syria by the way last time I checked
throwing rocks and bottles at law
enforcement generally doesn't count as
an application for refugee status and
any comparison by the way as Lindsey
Graham pointed out in a tweet today of
the Holocaust to modern-day Central
America does an extreme disservice to
those who suffered and were murdered
with unbelievable evil under Nazi
Germany the demonization of the Border
Patrol the Trump administration
continued all over TV predictable but
sad take a look we have plenty in this
country plenty to share plenty for
everybody
and I think we need to remember that the
reason we're great is because of this
melting pot of immigrants there has got
to be a pragmatic and compassionate
answer here that does not involve tear
gassing children that is not who America
is using tear gas in this situation does
not seem justified we are investigating
the facts on the ground but the border
tries to history of using unnecessary
force here we look at children get being
subjected to tear gas that's the United
States causing that that's outrageous
she's on the wrong side of history and
the wrong side of decency but we are not
a military dictatorship and the military
does have a certain level of
Independence he is the
commander-in-chief but the military also
does have the authority to decide for
themselves where there are more lines
that they will overall across so what
should Border Patrol do when they're
being hit with rocks and bottles and
other things what you just saw is just
pure politics of motion people literally
line to you you saw the video we'll show
it again tonight
in 2013 interestingly during the height
of the Obama administration guess what
Border Patrol agents did the exact same
thing quote they use pepper spray to
fend off a group of a hundred migrants
who attempted to rush the same exact
port of entry so where is the mainstream
left-wing media's outrage then you know
where would democratic tweets Democrats
tweeting dramatic tweets and accusing
the president of all sorts of things of
course that was then this is now and
while the security threats of unvetted
immigration remain the same the politics
of the left have changed and changed
dramatically we've shown you the video
over and
over again they now believe it's
politically expedient to push for open
borders unfettered immigration sanctuary
cities the end of ice and that's why I
Democratic presidential hopeful Kamala
Harris actually compared so well there's
a perception out there isn't there with
ice in the KKK
now the left is trying to score
political points over what is now an
actual real crisis our Border Patrol
agents deserve our protection the rule
of law needs to be adhered to they don't
seem to care about the five hundred
criminals that Mexico and the US have
identified as having infiltrated the
caravan they don't care about the
extreme security risks associated with
illegal immigration they sure as hell
don't care that each illegal immigrant
according to a study out three weeks ago
that successfully enters the country
caused you the American taxpayer I'm at
round seventy thousand dollars per year
and sadly the element the left only
cares about winning no matter what the
cost no matter the damage no matter the
risk they're not getting rocks hurled at
them of bottles hurled at them clearly
political sadly this is just the
beginning let me make a prediction over
the next two years the left soul focus
will be destroyed Trump for years I have
warned you what about the five forces
out to destroy this president we've had
two years of non-stop attempts at D
legitimizing a duly elected president
you have the Democrats won the
mainstream media to the deep state three
weak Republicans for never Trump errs
they want to be proven right so mark my
words as we now head into January the
hate Trump House of Representatives when
they take power those five forces will
align and spew anti-trump vitriol every
second every minute every hour every day
the good news for us
they will overreach they will really
extend what they think is a mandate that
is not what they won't do sadly is
anything that will help the people of
this country you the people we the
people and that is the most if right now
we have the most radical left-wing House
of Representatives this country has ever
seen there are no more moderates
and of course the deep state side well
we've been witnessing Muller's destroyed
Trump partisan which on play out for
what the past 558 days and breaking
tonight this is huge news Muller is
alleging that his top target Paul
Manafort remember the target was about
loan applications years ago tax
violations years ago they're saying that
he lied to investigators after agreeing
to his plea deal we also learned that
Roger stones associate jerome corsi he's
rejected a plea deal from robert muller
the deal involved Corsi pleading guilty
to one count of perjury greg jarrett
will join us in a moment here's what he
noted what we're seeing here is the
classic muller Waisman tactic using
threats and coercion to get people
basically to test the lie in other words
what that usually means is you either
tell us what we want you to tell us you
lie or you're gonna get punished think
about this if they said what Muller
wanted korzy and Matta for all I have to
do is say what they're basically saying
they want to hear they would likely get
a better deal by not doing this it means
both those men know that they may be
risking spending the rest of their lives
in jail and they have decided not to do
it this is a profound development and I
can't wait to hear the full backstory in
both cases look at general Flynn 30-plus
years serving his country the FBI didn't
even think he lied home he didn't think
he lies struck didn't think he lied but
he was on the brink of bankruptcy had to
sell his home to pay his attorneys so
they turned the screws probably
threatened to go after his own son and
now he's awaiting sentencing and by the
way they didn't even believe he lied
then there's George papadopolis he's now
in jail for two weeks he feels like he
was set up big time just look at his
tweets he'll be locked up for the next
fourteen days we'll talk to him
afterwards and does any of this have
anything to do with Russia collusion
nothing because there is none there is
no call trump Russia collusion but we
have been able to reveal on this program
Clinton collusion but they cared about
collusion they certainly don't care
about that because if they did they
would look at sir
valence abuse Oh unmasking abuse leaking
intelligence abuse lying to FISA courts
and committing fraud upon the courts
they would look at the circular leaks of
the phony dossier they look at how the
dossier was used to lie to the American
people before the election and how
Hillary paid for those Russian lines
that never told the FISA Court this no
one seems to care in Muller's office
Hillary's bought and paid for Russian
lies now this has literally become the
biggest travesty of justice a one-sided
witch-hunt that has no interest in truth
or real russia collusion hillary can pay
for russian lies they don't care they
can propagandize and lie to the american
people they don't care even the author
of the dossier
Christopher steel even he doesn't stand
by the dossier so my warning is buckle
up because Democrats they're going to
rehash all of it when Democrats take the
house we'll have a lot more later in the
program but first in just moments we're
going to take you live as you can see to
Mississippi the president is currently
about to rally voters ahead of this
important runoff tomorrow between
Republican senator Cindy hyde-smith and
Liberal Democrat Mike sp
this is a really important race that is
definitely in play if you're in
Mississippi but there's a win for the
Republican hyde-smith well that means an
opportunity for the GOP to solidify its
lead in the Senate it's either going to
be 53 47 or 52 48 and remember votes in
the Senate are so important especially
when it comes to things like Oh
confirming constitutionalists
originalist justices for the president
to make important appointments like
replacing Jeff Sessions and you have
Democrat might as Mike s be a far left
liberal that clearly supports Chuck
Schumer and the rest of his radical
Democrats already in Washington
he's been dodged by many ethical
questions stemming from his recent work
lobbying work for an alleged war
criminal from the West African country
the Ivory Coast SP was also forced out
of the Clinton administration back in 94
while under investigation for allegedly
receiving improper gifts while he was
acquitted of the 30 felony charges the
Independent Counsel found a pattern
quote in proper behavior now regardless
of what the mainstream media wants you
to believe this race is very simple
hyde-smith is a vote for the Trump
agenda that means confirming originalist
justices a vote for SB is a vote for the
swamp and Chuck Schumer it's that simple
so Mississippi this race matters and I
hope you vote tomorrow